guys it's here officially I'm kind of
getting emotional thinking about it
because this has been probably one of
the biggest projects that I've ever ever
worked on and it's crazy because it is
something that isn't digital it is a
tangible analog book
thus the analog memoir subtitle and we
went back and forth for so long trying
to figure out a title and all of this
sort of happened out of the just a joke
like we were joking about oh wouldn't be
funny if it was called I just seen
joking about how I make fun of myself
because it's iJustine it wouldn't be
funny if I called analog memoir because
I started out as a blogger writing
digitally wouldn't it be really funny if
I dressed up like Steve Jobs as an ode
to my hero
and that was my book cover yeah all of
these pieces sort of just fell together
and everything ended up just exactly how
I envisioned it but I didn't actually
envision this it just sort of all
happened and I think that is sort of a
testament to this whole internet thing I
never tried to do this I never wanted to
be a youtuber I never even wanted to be
in front of the camera like this is all
just something sort of happened it's the
story it sits in here like writing it
down and seeing it like in actual text I
am so overwhelmed actually I don't wanna
start crying on camera because I have
some other things that I have got to
tell you the book will officially be
released on June 2nd and I'm really
excited because I will be doing a book
tour and the first job is going to be
New York on May 31st at bookcon or you
guys can actually get an early copy and
I'll be signing autographs and I'll be
signing them all for you and just I am
most excited about doing the book tour
because meeting you guys is the
highlights of everything it is the
inspiration that I think all of us
youtubers need not just me when we meet
you guys it makes this whole crazy thing
actually real we see you we see your
texts we see your tweets but actually
getting to meet you at events is
it's it's kind of overwhelming it's
overwhelming for us it's overwhelming
for you and you guys are why we do this
like I said this wasn't something that
many of us ever thought was gonna happen
and Here I am and here you are this back
text is actually not finished on this
copy and I'm really excited for you to
read it because it basically sums up
everything that that I think yeah anyway
I'm just going to move on you guys can
pre-order it I seen book calm which also
links to my new website iJustine calm or
you guys are gonna actually be able to
interact and have conversations and this
is what I'm so excited about I'll go
further into detail about that later
make sure you guys save all of your
pre-order codes and all the emails
because I'm gonna be doing giveaways I'm
gonna be calling you guys I'm gonna be
doing all kinds of fun stuff just as a
big thank you for pre-ordering and for
getting the book and just being so
freaking supportive I wish that there
was more of me so that I could just like
go and visit you guys maybe I'll even
show up at your freaking house to
deliver the book I don't know that's
kind of my goal scenario so we'll see if
I can actually get that approved by the
people who might want to approve such
things either way I'll see you guys at
the book tour I would try to get to as
many cities as possible I want to go
international and that would probably be
the coolest thing ever is to get to go
visit you guys it'll also be available
in your local bookstores again you can
get at a Gesine book calm is the
Internet's fantastic and yes to answer
your question I will be doing an
audiobook yes I will be reading it with
my own voice let me see if there's
anything that I left out that I wanted
to tell you guys it's available June 2nd
hydrastine book calm May 31st a book con
I think that's it
I think I said everything that I wanted
to say say what you need to say I think
I said it likes John it's official I
hope you love it
I am so excited I'm so excited I could
cry I love you guys so much and I don't
know what else to say I'll see you soon
I don't want to cry I don't cry